did you speak to Prince William yes well
I mean I met him very briefly in like a
lineup we are the middle classes notes
so yeah I mean I met him what did you
say I'm playing your grandad what No so
the lady who was doing the lineup said
and this is Matt and he's about to play
and I thought don't say it don't say it
don't say he's about to play Prince
Philip and I thought oh god and then she
said if I see and have you got any
advice for him and I thought god I'm
gonna die you're all experience was
slightly him over the fact that you just
had a baby I just had a baby like four
months before I'm an idiot you know how
that happens right yeah why didn't we
think about at the time and then yeah
yeah yeah yeah still got it yeah yeah
yeah nursing go to the trailer yeah yeah
I was a lunatic and I think I genuinely
think I mean yes I was a lunatic don't
you were amazing she's amazing I mean
well yeah you were amazing
what sort of breastfeeding the Queen an
odd thing
you have to do that I don't know and
ever I talk about expressing milk I
always do that it's electronic when it
goes it goes Matt knows a sample cause
like every morning in the makeup chair
there pop like a like a cow
wash it up have a cup of tea and and
without fail someone would say someone's
phone's going during that so I'm like a
cow yeah every yield Graham Norton here
if you'd like to see even more stuff
like that then hit subscribe or don't
it's a free world but I know what I do
in that situation